before I run out of time and I have two
professors here I want to ask you guys
what is going on at college
because we talked about a lot here and
but I've been on a college campus in
quite some time it's just what I read
but I do want to just ask you about
certain statistics because one thing
that I think you might agree on
is that there has been and people may
not be aware of is that there has been a
sea change at who is running the college
it used to be the professors right and
now it's administrators some of the
numbers I find mind-boggling Yale has
undergrads and 3 500
administrators yeah
um Stanford has 10
896 managerial and professional staff
these are not the professors ten
thousand first of all what do these
people do
What do the
3 500 and the 10 000 people do at Yale
in Stanford I'd love to know have Adam
Dan well I think it's a very important
issue so what's happened in the last
generation or generation in uh and a
half there's been a sea change of
transformation in the American
University I would say a consumer Center
transformation where the student has
effectively become the consumer and and
the college experience quote unquote has
become the center of what college is
about as opposed to education and this
has had a number of negative effects
perhaps most important colleges now many
colleges many universities are now run
like businesses and I just want to get
this statistic out because it's very
crucial about 70 percent of professors
are non-tendered track that means they
are paid very low that means they don't
have any job stability really often
times and that means they don't have any
benefits in in the 1970s that number was
a round of reverse roughly 70 to 75
percent of the professoriate were
tenured so now when you run the college
like a business you basically move away
from the educational purpose which I
think Lynn and I would agree is is the
purpose of college and I think Bill you
oftentimes talk about you know college
students shouting down speakers things
like that I think are profoundly
connected to the college student being
considered a consumer that they're there
to have an experience and they pay a
ton of money for it and they get an
enormous debt for it so they're sure as
hell going to have fun and I think if we
want to and that's fun
speakers oh no no no it is for some
people but I think that uh it's more
about drinking and doing drugs and
having sex and it's less about education
so I think if you wanted to you know
change what you're talking about and and
for professors to have more of a role
you need to change what college actually
is but what do these people do
what are they doing I just want to know
I I read recently like the tech industry
just had a big bloodbath and they fired
up a whole bunch of people and then it
came out a lot of them admitted they did
nothing well they like they weren't even
pretending we didn't do anything
they have me what do these people do
they have meetings meetings they write
memos
they oversee the enforcement of
regulations regulations they cultivate
alumni for donors and they kowtow to
their clients the students because as
Danny says it's a consumer driven thing
that's going on what they don't do is
educate anybody they don't write any
books
they don't produce new knowledge but I
just want to make a quick final point I
think you see this in the larger
American economy the rise of so-called
jobs where a lot of where a lot
of people are sitting at their desk all
day being changed to the last tyranny in
American Life the workplace uh and not
really producing much or doing much and
so I think what you see in the
University mirrors what's happening
throughout the society as a whole